voilà pour résumer parce que c'est un
résumable le début du film célia vous
même êtes en train de faire son ménage
elle aperçoit un paquet de cigarettes et
l'allumé smoking on sonne à la porte
elle va ouvrir dans le second film célia
ne cède pas à la tentation
no smoking et c'est la bonne qui va
ouvrir les deux films sont donc
différents ils se déroulent bien sûr sur
la même thématique tous les événements
sombres vécues à des intervalles de cinq
secondes de cinq jours de cinq semaines
2 5 ans alors ce qui est tout à fait
originale dans ce qui est déjà tout à
fait original dans sa conception c'est
qu'il y en a en tout et pour tout deux
acteurs vous même vous sabine vous tenez
cinq rôles c'est ça et vous pierre
quatre rôles alors vous il ya des lignes
est complètement perdue en mouvement
dans le tournage non vous saviez plus je
vous ai dit vous savez exactement vous
en étiez un petit moment à s'habituer à
cette gymnastique et puis nous on compte
rester même amusant parce que ça nous
empêcher de nous nous lasser sur un
personnage puisque on était obligé de
sortir et doit venir nous mêmes dans
quelqu'un d'autre donc au contrat serait
plutôt un bon jeu si les personnages
sont vraiment bien différent
physiquement enfin on veut pas se
tromper quand même ils sont bien
différents mais vous êtes refusé à des
artifices de grimage n'aurait pas de
prothèse pas de lentilles de contact pas
de pas de faux accessoires le minimum
via les différences mais selon fin c'est
un petit peu comme les jeux d'enfants
que c'est les enfants disons qu'on sera
on dit qu'on serait alors on aime on
pense que les gens croiront à ça aussi
alors ce double film est tiré de 2,8
pièce écrite par un anglais ça s'appelle
intimate etc sien je sais ça à la avec
bourne voilà une véritable logique de
théâtre puisque c'était huit pièces
différentes avec deux fins différentes à
chaque fois donc il fallait qu'ils
allaient soir au théâtre
absolument mais cette étape oui c'est
formidable c'est est irréalisable au
fond profondément au théâtre c'est pour
ça c'est ce qui intéresse et rennes et
j'ai glissé dis bien pour une fois c'est
le cinéma qui va faire que ce théâtre là
existe donc tout à fait original et ça a
été adapté par ceux qui ont déjà fait
cuisine et dépendances qui fonctionnait
un petit peu sur le même système voilà
jean pierre bacri jaoui
vous avez tourné c'est un film très
anglais vous avez tourné dans la
campagne anglaise hanoune a tourné à
arpajon pas du tout
au milieu des haricots dans une campagne
anglaise totalement artificielle
reconstituée en studio c'est un autre
des paris du film c'est à dire que
complètement tout ce retard est derrière
et tout est reconstituée en studio et on
finit par ne plus savoir si on est
dehors dedans ne sait plus très bien
ça fait partie du jeu général s'est
embrouillé tous aller mais tout est
facile ça t'inspire le budget pour le
film si c'est entièrement décor au
dessus de ses moyens je crois au maroc
par rapport à l'étendue du projet je
crois que c'est maintenant aux alentours
de 50 millions et de l'argent mais ce
qui proportionnellement pour deux films
aussi lourd n'est pas si cher et votre
chaîne d'ailleurs et pour productrice du
film vous le savez donc nous espérons
bien rentrer dans nos sous libyenne a
laissé qu'une malle souhaitons
mutuellement le fish 10e a failli
s'appeler ou bien on vient parce que
c'est vraiment un jeu pour les
téléspectateurs
on a tous dû faire à un moment ou un
autre des choix en disant donc si
j'avais choisi d'aller en vacances là
plutôt si j'avais choisi de divorcer me
marier ou réciproquement
on donne le pouvoir à des gens qui
vivent un parcours une vie de leurs
diabré coûté vous regrettez au fond
d'avoir fait comme ça bon vous donne la
possibilité de faire autrement fait
autrement et on va voir ce qui se passe
pour vous donc jamais on peut faire ça
nous faisait toujours ah si j'avais fait
ça ou celle ci j'avais dit ça je suis
certain que ça devrait marcher autrement
et puis bah voilà là on dit très bien
alors on vous montre comment ça marche
si vous aviez fait autrement je me dis
pas comment ça marche on sera vraiment
voir les films dans n'importe quel homme
il ya même une petite préférence c'est
quoi ces concessions au barça dans
n'importe quel ordre
oui il faut tirer au ca fait conseillé
d'avoir une pièce et il a plutôt fins
purement et simplement
alors cinq mois de tournage en gros et
trois mois de répétitions au bout de
huit mois vous supportiez encore et on
nous a écrit fait ces phases approfondie
et rapport que ce soit encore possible
oui on sait c'est une balise fait un
beau voyage et peut-être au fond le
souhait qu'on peut émettre c'est que une
époque où tout va si vite comme ça quand
on vous voit faire le journal par
exemple c'est très facile on voit faire
défiler des choses si fondamentales
comme ça on se dit que peut-être là on
offre au spectateur la possibilité de
voyager peut-être une journée entière
dans des histoires qui sont à la fois
des siennes et pas les siennes et de
rêver comme ça c'est un autre rythme de
vie peut-être c'est ça le cadeau parce
que c'était très amusant de voir les
deux films devraient même journée
justement vous voyez c'est pour résorber
ses week-ends
oui j'adore
la journée s'est fait rare de gens se
déplacent pour des événements
exceptionnels moi je crois que c'en est
un c'est une manière de regarder le
monde autrement
merci beaucoup sa vie une pierre donc
bonne vie à smoking no smoking d'alain
resnais qui sort mercredi dans les
salles
vers une heure du matin le